all right and we are live
flashpoint morning lighthouse edition
let's go out he watches us breakfast
gotta get it in but yes absolutely yeah
Friday morning man got to get to the
lighthouse early right fancy sir Osiris
a big circle of mercury not a solo
nightfall last night which is just to
get a little more eye opening about a
few things we'll discuss waiting
basically for next week just to see what
is gonna come but we got a little
preview of some passion notes so I've
got some got some words for what we got
we'll have some things to talk about and
just get a even just another revelation
in the world of destiny too and just
kind of some of the creators out there
some of the content and just some of the
major sites that follow this we'll have
some things to talk about so oh yeah oh
yeah it's good it's good this one's a
big stuff to talk about well at least
coming up place you see ya next week
will be a lot of detail to talk about
this week is a lot of just world stuff
to talk about real life things are
happening absolutely absolute and as you
guys know this week at Bungie drops was
a fairly short one so this part could be
sure but our discussion afterwards make
it longer so flashpoint Long Point you
know so this we get Bungie they just
discuss the faction Early's are coming
this is the last one for season two
you're gonna see a future war cult that
has a chance but honestly most people
have talked to I don't know if they care
you have new monarchy with a grenade
launcher and they're terrible and you
have to sniper rifles and I was
literally going through weekly reset I
was like okay let me login not look and
see what my real reaction is when I look
at these sniper rifles both of them have
the same perk at the end so there's not
a whole lot of distinction between them
ones rapid ones mid but the perk is that
when you get like critically wounded it
will reload ammo in the magazine I'm
going okay so let me think how this is
gonna go I'm gonna get critically
with a sniper rifle I'm probably gonna
reload so this perk doesn't be no good
and it's on both English like are you
hitting me so yeah completely completely
some of the guns from the drops that you
can get from the engrams I hear okay but
I mean the ones you're shooting for 50
grand in case you don't pick the right
faction like that's that's our choices
for the last one they definitely go it
with the Bing basically as I said they
kind of fizzled out to me right now it's
all about like meta like if I was gonna
do it to me it's just all about prepping
for the new meta with the hope that you
know snipers get to where they need to
be that kind of bit so it really didn't
interest me I mean at this point I've
got like a whole bunch of snipers I've
been just kind of like sitting on in the
vault and just ready to bust those bad
boys out you know once they say it was
about to bust open carry you know with
the countdown on a vote fix it's 1,300
I'm like aw we passed their team it's
been 1208 for a little while be the
point that we'll talk about later but
yeah so not much there so we'll see who
wins but I think most of us are kind of
lackluster on worrying about it so if
you don't pick the right faction I don't
think you'll need to worry about
spending the 50 grand that's basically
all exactly you'll be alright
so I talked about the nightfall scoring
in challenge cards a little bit but
mostly about the nightfall specific
rewards so they bolded the one title
from a previous discussion or section
each terrible villain that players face
[Music]
the tumbles to the ground as they
collapse in a pile of Bones cool in
theory sweet so conquering nightfall
should be a badge of honor with players
to show off their achievements with
dynamic emblems exclusive auras and
hopefully some new stuff now last week
they asked us and they were even posting
on Twitter it's like do you guys want to
see these rewards and I guess the answer
is no unless they're gonna post them up
in patch notes because we have no idea
of what they're gonna be I feel with
this I do think that um I agree with the
logic that they don't need to be shown
all the night for rewards you know you
don't want to spoil the whole thing but
I do would like to get a glimpse of just
one yeah I was like that was my reply
when I think it was the Dylan sent it
out I was like can I just have like
maybe just like a quarter of a picture
of one just like give us a glimpse it
looks sloppy it was a little snippet you
know saying just to get an idea because
again we just want to see the level of
the quality right because you know we've
seen certain things like when we did the
was the crucible ones
no I mean as far as the ornaments are
concerned right we're just like we need
to see some flame I want to be shining
out you know and see something that kind
of thing so it is kind of fun yeah so it
was nice to have seen something and I
didn't want to see it all it's like hey
we have you know not that many strikes
depending on weapons or armor what the
drops are right not that many but I
always like to have seen just a little
glimpse but what they're saying about
these drops is there gonna be supposedly
hard to get so these words have a chance
to drop when you complete a nightfall at
any difficulty which is we'll come back
to that here in a second okay you can
increase your chances using challenge
card modifiers to set a higher personal
best scores which is a weird sentence so
you can see were chances for the drop
using the challenge card
modifiers to set higher personal bests
scores and like yes I know the challenge
card gets you best scores but I guess it
increases your drop chance as well I
don't know earning these items may take
multiple attempts to receive a drop as
they are meant to be rare rewards so
they just so that as I said last week we
gathered feedback on how the comedian
like to discover these rewards either
throw a quick T's on here the blog or
from those among you who find them so
basically they just say and we're gonna
be watch the legends unfold so if you
find one out that are in the world
take a picture post on Twitter you know
maybe one of the early ones if you're
playing a reset so exactly so what do
you think do you think they should be
from the normal nightfall do you think
it should be prestige only they want
them to be rare yeah I mean prestige
needs to have some type of flair to it
too so I mean I've been different you
know right now you know my main concern
with just over what stuff the emblem
stuff doesn't doesn't excite me that
much and my thing is if you're gonna do
Elam's
you got a do emblem right you've got a
you got to make them shine you got to
make them very ornate you know that kind
of thing so right now to me you know
they're okay it's not the worst thing
I've ever seen but the variations to me
is it's still not enough or I just want
it very you know like do have it some
type of animation going on you know they
get you shot yeah and then so I mean you
can run somebody could run in challenge
card
you know highest score difficulty you
could run your first night fall in 270
and get the same thing yeah so again
just kind of given the easier the easier
the route more people will take that so
I mean if they do it once and they get a
high score they're not gonna grind
against the you know now they're saying
if you do the procedure supposedly you
have a higher chance but I guess we'll
see how that goes
I don't know at least putting it behind
even just a prestige completion maybe
not the you know the hardest lowering
your level down and all that stuff but
in general I don't know I would have
been okay with it behind prestige would
have given me a reason to run prestige
yeah actually I'm leaning I'm leaning
towards that direction as well I think
you're right I think it has to be
pristine you have to make that
distinction I would agree with that I
think I mean you can throw everybody can
get 3035 at this point and you don't
have to lower your damage down you just
have to finish it so you just you know
throw the damage multiplier on there and
you're just running a prestige you know
I haven't had an issue finish finishing
a prestige with friends it's been a
little bit of a struggle when the timer
was there but now the timer is not there
yeah I think it'll be alright
so absolutely shoutouts at a time and I
be
[Laughter]
some of these with guides but yeah
esoteric still crushing them so hats off
to that guy you still killin it hey
zombies competitive housekeeping so they
are going to work on some quitter
penalties you so the biggest thing about
competitive play list is you can't join
in progress so if you leave you pretty
much screw your whole team over though
they want to find a way to counter that
and give you incentive not to yes so
they're working on temporary
restrictions potentially up to a 30
minute length for habitual quitters if
you do it once or Emily you may have
like you know a 5 minute thing and if
you you know have food delivered you go
get that you come back you may have to
wait a couple minutes not the end of the
world but you know they're trying to
basically make it to where they want to
make sure you have a solid connection I
love how they have that in like are
based on your connections because we
don't have dedicated servers yep and
just throwing their hands up on that one
again I mean you have yeah if you want
something to be competitive you're gonna
have a point where you have rain to
playlist and you still do not have
dedicated servers like I don't know I
play on PC more than most and I don't
feel it too much on there I feel like if
I went back to console I'd probably feel
the lag more so PC feels a little bitter
just because it's through battlenet and
it's probably mostly solid connections
but yeah console I I probably feel your
pain on that was probably my biggest
disappointment when bestie two got
announced in the very beginning because
at at the very minimum I thought this
would be okay they going all out they
gotta have dedicated servers this time
and to me just I don't know if that's an
Activision thing you know cuz it seems
to be consistent across the board with a
lot of their games including Call of
Duty and that's a problem you know
especially when these franchises are
making and generating as much you know
money as they are you know they have to
you have to commit to the base and you
have to have dedicated servers
everything perfect but it's better than
peer-to-peer that much pressure and that
just seems like one of those that a lot
of a ton of people and asked for the ask
forum for most of us
it's like how do you not I did not do
that even maybe if QuickPlay is
peer-to-peer and then competitive at
least they make that a dedicated server
so people can't DDoS people can't drop
you like make it at least the
competitive environment something that
is that lives up to the name yeah
absolutely they're also saying they're
gonna work on some security features
they're not obviously telling us what
they are so people can't figure out how
to get around then which is I mean
that's fair like saying I'll be like hey
this is how you break our system well
that's yeah they're not gonna do that
the lighthouse go here so no so they've
got some stuff they're working on so
they can detect cheaters quicker and
basically give them you know their
penalties quicker so it's a good thing
that they said their work isn't done
mores to come in 1.20 basically right
now you know try not to quit if you're
going in the competitive playlist just
be ready to be there or at least be
there long enough for your match don't
uh don't go in and be like you have to
bail and if you bail and you have 30
minutes well you're probably not in the
house anyway so probably exactly cut you
shenanigans you know match finish
alright so I will save my thoughts until
the end no because I believe in texted
you about one last night okay oh here we
go
so we got a one dot one dot for a little
preview you know this is by no means
everything because they're gonna have
the sandbox gun changes and things like
that in there so all that stuff will be
but there's a glimpse of some of the
stuff we can expect you guys give me my
dog barking in the background sorry
they're going for a walk shout out to
Saladin's wolves yeah you guys and check
it out on Twitter I put Twitter I posted
a pic yesterday excited I'm facing the
right direction so check it out though
so when a player playing striker
crucible activities repeat reduction
will be introduced to prevent players
from playing the same strike or crystal
have multiple times okay this is good
why is this March I don't know but this
is good there's a lot of that that's
gonna happen in the exotic repetition
reduction will prevent players from
receiving the same exotic reward
multiple times in a row from exotic
engrams players can still receive repeat
exotic awards from milestones and other
sources you've got and pull death
the max power handicap for 40 to 45 on
the nightfall challenge card yet the
timer to activate patrols has been
reduced from three second to one second
another comment there but I'll save it
for a bit because that issue where
players could be prevented from reaching
the boss encounter on a garden world now
this one I haven't done I sold it a lot
last week and failed by the way but if
you I don't know if I should have broken
we can't get there not platform but you
know fixing the strike is a good thing
for sure absolutely an issue work but
again they're fixing an issue where
players couldn't get to the boss
encounter of a strike and when did curse
of Osiris come out was it was it
December yeah December yeah Oh mid
December to late March yes like it
hadn't happened to me but if it I don't
know when it happened so fixed an issue
where some emblems were not displaying
the statistic they track QA testing got
a get a get a get a QA in now this one
actually happened to me recently I don't
know if it was like a background fix or
what but this one actually notice
recently I'm like why am i fighting my
shader page replying or previewing a
shader on an item or yes I've had this
and it'll bump me back up to the top
yeah like what I was like I'm sitting
there fighting and I'm going alright
this can't be right so it was good for
them to a go just to make Beaman I'm not
crazy
yeah okay so we can go back to the top
here I mean the one about repeat
reduction on playlists like crucible and
strike activities that's good I mean
that should have been there give you
some variety it's gonna happen sometimes
but I've hear people talk about like hey
I seem to always start on this one or I
play this one like three times in a row
so absolutely some type of thing in the
background to be like hey you've played
this one at least don't even if you go
every other even though I played like
you wouldn't play it again so some way
to distract hey this is the last map
they played in crucible even if it was
like 20 minutes ago maybe not throw them
in the same one now if you're with a
group yeah maybe a little harder but
generally I think people see more
repetitions than they should absolutely
this day under right no no you go you go
no no I'll just saying this is wrong to
write a feature and it's just like you
know this is what needs to
it's like you go through that that rut
you playing a couple of crucible matches
and then ultimately it's just like damn
this map again
and it just seems to happen way too much
so that is much needed mm-hmm for sure
as many people are gonna be jumping into
crucible a little bit more with that
stuff coming next week we've got
playlists for rumble 66 iron banner got
that rotation coming in so excited to
see and mayhem mayhem if nothing else
just be a little crazy fun absolutely
alright so bullet points you I'm gonna
let you go first I think I think I'm
surprised you on this with the exotic
repetition reduction okay um I'm
probably gonna go opposite for you
opposite only for one reason your whole
point I already know what it is you are
correct needs to get fixed and it needs
to be something outside of you know what
the milestones think I completely feel
your pain that no players can still
receive repeated exotic rewards from
milestones and other sources that
becomes annoying my issue is just that
at this point it's like what exactly
don't we not you know we not have so
it's like I mean what here's my question
to you like not saying that this is
correct like what that that problem is
not an issue it is an issue with my
issue is like at this point like when
you get your fifth you know what is it
knucklehead radar what hunter exactly I
mean what are you really doing but just
breaking it down for shards at this
point so I I think I just think that the
the issue ultimately there's still will
we always harp on not enough exotics and
then ultimately the exotic source is
just too easy to get and I think
ultimately they need to reduce it and
and just make it it's difficult to get
it cuz I just feel like we're just
reigning exotics everybody you know so
that's just where I'm at with it but I I
know you're about to go so let me get my
coffee I don't know you but going right
and I totally honestly agree I mean with
I played on PS of split cuz I played on
ps4 from release and then I waited for
PC and then I'm gonna shift it over so
what I have on ps4 and dumped at
Fairmont time into I don't have that
anymore
so PC I don't have everything so when I
do get four of the same set of gloves
five of the same chest for a warlock
like when I have stuff like that and
there are things I haven't received yet
that's when this tends to bug me so
that's where splitting the time between
ps4 and I haven't played as much as some
like Mesa shown probably has like 600
hours I probably have you know 200 on PC
or something like that but I played on
ps4 as well so I was like I've split my
split my time and haven't been as into
it you know jumped off one monster in
the world and as you guys know many of
us have taken little breaks and not been
doing it as much but absolutely all that
aside it happened to me again literally
I had to in my inventory literally on my
character and then one in the vault it's
the a on safe gloves and we all know
they're kind of trash oh it was trash
yeah yeah and it's the whole like a on
the three for each character they're all
pretty terrible so I had two of those on
my character finished up the nightfall
went over dozens of all and be like
alright what am I gonna get I got some
legendary and then I got these gloves
again I'm like I literally got those
like that was the last exotic I got I
feel on this character was the same one
so just the fact that I'm getting
duplicates that consistently now you're
gonna tell me the only thing you're
fixing is exotic engrams I know they
throw them at us in many other places
between milestones trying to think of
what else milestones is the big one I
get them from I guess probably from I've
seen them in chests that's really gonna
turn into an Engram so if not an Engram
and not milestones I guess I don't know
milestones is the big one but either way
the fact that it's like they only fixed
half of it kind of like cuz I've done
that I've turned in an Engram and I've
turned in a milestone well if I get a
new thing in in gram but I go over to a
milestone and I get the same thing I
just got you didn't fixed your problem
yeah that was just one of those I was
reading through knows like it happened
to me literally before I read this U is
extra tight I was
yeah that means that's kind of one of
those you have to bash your head and go
okay you want to fix exotic repetition
reduction fix it completely or if you're
saying or give me some transparency to
say hey we got the exotic engrams fixed
we could get a look at your vault now
milestones pull from a different pool or
they look at different things and we're
working on changing that if they have
that explanation in there I would have
been less peeved at the whole bullet
point just because I would have known
why absolutely know if they still are
just like hey duplicates gonna happen we
don't care that's how some will read
this myself included at the time now
there may be more to it but again they
just don't tell us so a little extra
transparency if you're not gonna fix own
increased max power from 40 to 45 so 40
takes you from two basically to 95 so
now this will take you two to 90 so if
you're not 335 max you're actually gonna
be 289 so I don't know if they still do
it like every tin is a different level
of damage so if you're not at that 290
maybe it's gonna hurt more I don't know
if that's the reason for this this seems
random like already points to so a good
chunk to lower yourself so now 45 it's
odd I don't know what the point in that
is the next one basically just made me
laugh the timer to activate patrols has
been reduced from 3 seconds to 1 second
we did like 3 or 4 patrols to activate
that milestone I haven't done one since
there is no point in doing patrols done
zero zero with it you know pitchforks
were for this sort I mean if you're
going to start your character and you do
the patrols you're like oh yeah that did
take a while but it's been like months
since I've even thought about doing a
patrol so I had to remember that it was
slow so that was just weird and the rest
of it we kind of covered it's like you
know and fixing the shader inventory
thing that was good because I was just
going out of my mind for a second I'm
like why is this happening that's weird
so very annoying good to have that
acknowledged but outside of that next
week we do have that's one point one
point for coming buno servers will be
down 9:00 a.m. Pacific time they will be
coming up 11:00 a.m. Pacific so quicker
server time that I've actually done
which is nice
and I'm actually probably gonna be off
on Tuesday evening so you guys can check
me out probably look in it
sandbox playing or night fall scene of
things guys quicker so I'll be playing
that evening they have a couple things
as well spreading awareness now on this
one it cracks me up because I hate the
strike anyway so the strike activity
Exodus crash which is the one with the
guy who teleports and goes invisible
like 20 times yeah oh yeah yeah nobody
likes the strike everybody that I hear
it's like I've heard mark on garden
radio talk about it I've heard multiple
people like this strike is just and then
when you had a timer on it it was so
much worse because he's probably he
would be second it would be the worst oh
yeah that was definitely worse
yeah depending on your super you could
use Golden Gun with like celestial right
you could use void bomb but if you did
anything with like a continuous like if
I was gonna pop striker and hit slam him
he'll disappear before I get to finish
getting my damage off on my super so so
that one I hate that's right yeah that
was annoying but there's not just not
gonna be featured as at nightfall yes I
love that that's awesome news but why
tell us why so due to an own issue
preventing progress when players are
attempting to collect energy spikes so I
think it's the first two sections when
you're collecting those little blue
beams of light yes and that's been going
since literally The Prestige nightfall
was that like the first time so it's
been an issue for a while our current
goal is to resolve this issue in one
point two point oh you don't even have
that many strikes in the first place the
ones for mercury are duplicate
submissions with the ending of it cut
off yes and now you have another strike
that doesn't work that most of us hate
anyway come on strikes need some needle
and I don't know man how's work okay so
here is the thing and this is where I
come back to like Monster Hunter scaled
things well certain things will scale
for the number of people in any game
they have a way to do that if I'm gonna
go in solo for something gonna go in
with a team of three do you feel that
should be the same strike
I shall have to put the same amount of
damage my example before you answer that
is take a night in a strike you're gonna
have an elite night so the orange bars
they're pain in the butt I'll literally
unload a clip on them and then they pop
their shield up there they're black
shield and they get health ok so they do
that for a little while and then they
shimmy behind the wall that give their
other energy shield up I'm literally
just dumping clips into these guys and
one of them took me like two minutes to
kill cuz by myself without missing him
that much
shield getting health back shield giving
this other one back shield shield like I
can't finish a clip before a shield
comes back up now I know with a group
they could probably do more damaging
kill them quicker but by myself that's
just like tediously frustrating like why
am i doing that
yeah oh if they scale the solo players a
little bit more it doesn't have to be
like a hundred percent to two hundred
percent maybe it's just like Oh some
difference between them would be nice to
do it and it's like and I could probably
use rockets and things board but it's
also the idea of when I go somebody has
an arc shield so say a knight has an arc
shield and I shoulder charge them and I
don't even completely drop his shield
and he's discouraging at the end of the
day a little bit godlike and this is a
normal this isn't even prestige animal
wow I was like and it was like shield
bash like or not shield bash but
probably the same thing if I run in
charge and I match his shield type with
an arc charge like you know shoulder
charge I should probably at least drop
his shield then back off and shoot him
if I can even drop his shield with a
charge of the same yeah you'll die yeah
that better itself but yeah I don't mind
scene except this crash go away it's
totally fine fix it but you know fix the
boss too he's just fun they also said
the removal of radar from competitive
and trials will also you can't like
bring the radar back with knucklehead
radar for example so they anything that
changes radar perks is not going to
change as it should as you know we want
this to be a competitive mode no radar
so one
here's otherwise so exci quickly so
exactly that's basically it had a couple
couple videos always good to check those
out I just appreciate just out there
editing or just a compliment there I was
cool so finally we've got speaking of
the sandbox team they said one point one
point four had a few potential names
thrown around in development one team
member in particular campaigned it to be
called the supercharged update which
sounds cool I like it yeah to keep
communications clear and set
expectations about all the changes
ultimately decided would be the go fast
update so even apparently they're
thinking too much about the names need
to be working more on the content I'm
just giving them a hard time on that was
they have a name for whatever the need
is and certain charge actually just
reminds me of a car so I appreciate it
somebody's a car fan so that's all of it
they just said in their time in the play
test they feel the name be it go fast be
it superchargers whatever it is they say
it feels better
Tuesday will answer the questions if it
does but again it's just kind of one of
those they're waiting to see when they
when we get it on our hands I mean a lot
of extra damage in PvE I might be able
to kill those Knights good you suck
that's fine but in general just you know
giving us a little more feeling like a
guardian feeling like a god that's what
we want absolutely couple high scores on
here all of them are two of them are PC
number three actually looks like it's
coming from console notice the last week
one and two are still up there so the
people have figured out how to tweak the
lost sectors oh yeah if milking it doing
cheese's oh absolutely yeah and I wish I
wish they would fix this too it would
give even the people running for a high
score it's like so you'll see data or
esoteric or any of these guys going for
high scores and it's like they're not
gonna cheese them so there's could be a
high score it could not buzz like when
they run through and get it perfect it's
you know I like to see those but then
they don't get acknowledged because
people are cheese in it so it's kind of
annoying I haven't so like I have a
video doing Sabbath oon song and from
the middle section they did a Golden Gun
turned around finished him off before he
could even teleport again and they were
like hey Lia they didn't like
seventeen and a half minutes so it's
like they did it while they still could
get the time and the points and it was
like it was a cool run like I don't know
if is the fastest one ever but it was
just you they are still never gonna be
in here cuz they're not choosing it so
great just takes away though the fun so
next week everybody will be crunching
numbers seeing what weapons do what
seeing where things are at one point one
point four is coming on Tuesday Tuesday
in Bao let's go
so are you excited yeah I mean this is
for me this is definitely for me the
crucible you know needs the love we're
getting all those molds we're getting a
sandbox change you know I was looking
pointed this week that they did not go a
little bit more in depth but I mean they
they probably gonna save it actually for
you know to the date probably Tuesday
the day of you know as soon as it goes
live we'll get that patch drop as far as
everything and I think those are the
ones I always get excited about because
sometimes on occasion Bungie has been
known to sneak in an additional couple
of fixes of things that they didn't talk
about oh yeah there's gonna be something
people read and be like what exactly so
I want I'm curious to see how that pops
off on Tuesday you know listen this is
not the savior y'all like this is not
that but this is what I consider the
steps to get them because to me work the
way we look at it is you know at the way
at least I'm looking at it right now
because the state of the game is so bad
reddit is just awful right now it is
it's bad man I got a shout out a few
people to arm shout out to the black
link talking to him and uh destiny bro
let's go let's go it is just like you
know planet destiny is not doing they
swung back on a Content they're
hemorrhaging subs you know you've got
those of my god my god fall our place
was over there you know and it's just
you just look at the community I think
someone else put up a great Twitter
question I forgot who it was and he
basically pulled all the major players
in the Destiny community like why you
not playing destiny right now
and I think Italian had one of the best
answers and he was just like you know
they took three years of what we wanted
and feedback and decided to turn him
back on the base and not apply these
things and you know that that's
definitely a big factor amongst other
things but you know back to this whole
point I mean the way I look at is this
um may is the next big content they have
to go extra hard I think we're beyond
the point now of the taking Queen being
the savior I think it's so bad right now
buts that they have to go all out and I
think these kind of sandbox updates pre
are pre dlc will help so that the actual
waves once the game plays better you
know I'm saying yeah
then you get the next stage is the
weapons and all other stuff but what's
the game placement and it feels
different and then you throw on a good
nice deal see around it hopefully that
could get some goodwill going that can
get some excitement going so they've got
to get to it they've got to get to it
that's my feeling I wear yet with it huh
yeah I mean it was definitely sad to see
that you know for playing destiny that
the podcast and like the website and
stuff is definitely gonna be kind of
going away which was I mean yeah in
destiny was one of those that even I
turned to occasionally just depending on
what I was doing if I woke up late like
whatever they were I mean they were on
it and the guys over there for the first
couple years I mean you had you know dr.
Casey you had teff tee you had the solid
group vote bearing all them and they had
broken off so I mean they had gone to do
their other things you know differences
of opinion whatever but there were still
some guys in there trying to make it
work and unfortunately just with the
situation of destiny to losing content
losing followers losing players not
content but you know what I'm going with
this basically just they couldn't keep
it going and there's not enough traffic
to drive a website to drive a podcast
and hey those people anything to make it
worth their while it's and that's just a
sad state of things sad times well I
mean let me just be complete on full
transparency I mean me getting into
destiny for the first time what is this
game I remember I was there from the
beta and a half or whatever and I was
like all right this thing has a lot of
chip tremendously
your graphics look good you just saw the
potential I remember you know because d1
was so complex and trying to understand
and weapons and aim-assist and all these
terminology was like just blowing my
mind I was like you know this is my
first console MMO you know for FPS MMO
light man planet destiny was like my
resource like I would literally go in
there and compare the guns and go okay I
got this one I got this roll I got that
roll you know what's the advantages and
uh shout out to shout to the original
team my Colts men in those videos weapon
reviews things like that and you know
even the original guys that were part of
the guys like that was part like I would
tune in every week just to know what's
going on and and and what the meta
change and it was just it was just good
time and it's just weird just to see all
these outlets and it's like my Destiny's
childhood is good with like Toys R Us
close that was my toys but I get it I
can't even get mad man like I get it so
bad right now I can only I was going
through my mind is as sad as we are
right now thing I was going through my
mind is like how does fun Chiefy are you
embarrassed like how are you feeling as
a company right now that you have all
your major content creators haven't
turned their back on this game yeah I
was like turn their back maybe not
completely but they definitely whatever
you know said what I mean they have set
it down and turned they haven't like
said I'm never playing you again but
right now it's like you're not doing it
and I'm going max I was like whatever I
was like however you want to phrase it
yeah yeah I mean you know my back was a
little extreme of work but you know what
I mean what do people look for making
people up making announcements now this
do thing I'm you know let's talk about
the state of the channel the channel I'm
not doing this hey I can't play this
anymore it's just not fun to do this
anymore and people may do one video once
a week you'll see some pop up next week
for the the changes and things like that
there come
sandbox review you know Impa - might do
like review on a couple hand cans or
something all that stuff will come
through but again as we don't have
anything new to play we don't anything
going on when people figure out how
things feel what's working what isn't
you know does it feel better it's gonna
taper off again because again there's no
reason to keep going there's nothing to
grind for right now there's nothing to
work towards because everyone can get
that max level there's no different gun
and that kind of leads me to the other
thing we were talking about it's like I
mean you mentioned the reddit thread
that I saw and it was literally like
every content creator it's like they
pulled him and got him on there were so
many just saying it's like it doesn't
feel like home anymore it's three years
of things and we've said this before how
do you go through three years and just
throw it all out the window like they
learned the random roles were good
people were grinded for these yet
gunsmith stuff you have a gunsmith that
has just like random mods you can buy
he's not doing anything he has next to
no point you've got story missions you
can't go back and play unless it's the
three of the week and say I've got a
friend in town and I want to show them
that one mission on the Sun that looks
really cool and like if it's not the
right week I can't even show it to him
cuz I've already played through my
characters like I mean I just want to
throw one point shot to be kissed on the
chat he's just basically saying how
could they be embarrassed of them
counting all that money and I heard you
saying but here's the problem that was
launched money and I shall attempt a
piscatella we had him on our little
podcast yeah
and what was pretty surprising like the
last two to three MPD's destiny hasn't
even been in the top ten software sales
yeah I mean I'm not surprised nobody the
word of mouth isn't there anymore right
that's crazy that's unheard of you would
have said that you know in the beginning
a d1 site because even when the dark
below would you want to say that was
kind of like a low point for d1 you know
Polk did acolo like beginning the dark
below stage took a while to get what the
House of wolves right
you know I'm saying so it's just like
wow you know I think and again is that
it's that fear you know is that fear
when you look at Reddit and people are
like yo I think people may be done for
real this time
is rough couple of my I got see if I can
say right fool-killer and TF Chronos
come in there they're just saying
there's no one sent over to keep playing
they're not even on the twitch director
anymore
I mean if you see your numbers on twitch
drop and that's again that's a huge
platform now I mean when it comes out
yeah Mia pot I see I would be gonna say
curious when you had you know eater of
worlds which was the first expansion
when they did the race for whenever that
thing went live versus whatever happens
with this may expansion I don't know if
Mayes expansion is even gonna be as our
people have been getting gonna want to
do that Raider as much like I worry that
stuff like that has even fallen off yet
that's why to me the urgency is so key
and again I don't want to disrespect
anybody we don't know what's going on in
that building but at the same time it's
like dude all right let's just let's
just go what the I test says he bounces
does the I test say to you that there's
a sense of urgency what is the eye test
tell you I'm gonna ask you this question
so you define I test justify from
everything okay from what you've seen
from Bungie communication-wise um from
what you what they've outlined so far
that we know from this point from
development updates yada yada every
flashpoint that we talked about from
this point on in your opinion does this
scream a company that is urgent in
getting this game I'm just in terms of
speed in terms of urgency is this do you
sense that
what's your feeling am i blonde or like
what where you at with that so do I
think they have a sense of urgency yes
do you feel a sense of urgency when you
see these road maps that you know
they're trying to get this thing
back up and run it I mean not back up a
running like we gotta fix this like do
you get that I do to a point okay you
have ace so this is where I'm actually
gonna switch over you guys are watching
to Paul Tassie's article shout out
always good stuff got a cool right for
Forbes for video games I love that job
combination awesome so he said the
weirdest part of Destiny 2 and is a
recent article on yesterday morning is
that Bungie recognized its current
problems before release and this is
stuff we've talked about we've all
wondered so it's the famous example as
he said of the 10th better Devils okay
so I was like masterworks helped a
little bit as he mentioned but again
still once you get your master work
better Devils there's no point so there
are bigger problems that their
development calendar can't fix to me
unfortunately
what so when you say urgency I know in
there they probably are working tooth
and nail like there's no way they're not
working their tails off trying to get
everything done but in turn I don't know
why things still take so long right so
you've got a sandbox update it's our
first one six months later and that's
the other piece that he mentions in this
article you've got people and he said it
pretty well in the end he's like I don't
I just don't understand how Bungie
foresaw all these problems with loot
diversity balance update speed and so on
and didn't actually end up fixing the
issues they knew were a problem I think
doesn't even for two players would have
been a lot more accepting of certain
changes if there was actually gold at
the end of the rainbow that's a huge one
you had to have something to chase the
quickly updated and well-balanced game
they got a two well balanced but they
still update slow as molasses stuff went
in circles around them
yeah so it means yeah and that's what's
like your whatever whatever their
process is is not urgent enough for the
rest of the world
exactly oh that's the key and I'm not
saying they're not working hard it's
just their level of urgency like you
said might not meet fan expectation of
how fast this thing needs to turn around
because another thing Lord says he said
I don't know if he caught a tweet email
recently he had he said he hadn't put
out a destiny article in some time yep
and the minute he put that up bull he
said it was like 5,000 hits or whatever
the number was right yeah so it goes to
show you how ravenous the base is for
something to turn around right that this
is a game that people is even in its
darkest hour right now people are
clamoring you know if it did anything
positive to look at and see if it if it
can come back you know that kind of
thing and I think um well shut out the
thuggin duggan from IGN he made it tweet
wild back and it was really good he's a
destiny only game ii see like something
if i'm paraphrasing there's like
something if i think thats these the
only french i've i've seen where you
know the the dev portrays the fan base
and they keep forgiving them and they
come back ravenous life but it's like
it's like how many thoughts could you
keep doing that to your base that kind
of thing just ya know for sure it's just
one of those pieces where you have to
wonder they see other there are other
games out there now i don't know their
process i know they're heavy on data i
know they want to take their time but
again when you see things like okay so
everybody news for like the longest time
auto rifles have been one of the kings
for sure you know a couple hands like
dire promise that people use submachine
guns have kind of found their spot
rifles are still fairly solid to a point
of like they're not getting much of a
buff the whole world has known that for
six months pretty much from week one
so why destiny to and Bungie hasn't
tried to change you know buff up Scouts
buffa pulses why can't they do
stuff five months ago and keep rolling
with stuff and be like hey this change
is coming here okay see how this one
does this week all right well this gun
is completely broken let's just
deactivate it mm-hmm you may own it
it'll come back but right now it's like
just yeah activate I saw a couple things
and they lit have said fortnight weapons
currently bugged you know they're
unavailable right now yeah okay so it's
it's okay if you use it but right now
it's not working oh okay like I mean
just take the things out and work out
but those continuous updates like if we
we only pulse rifles were terrible like
nobody uses just go in there and give
them 10% buff see how it goes like I
know no arbitrary number but sometimes
like do a little testing like see how it
goes they've got their testers exactly
perfect when you bring it down to
percent later but if you're doing
continual changes not taking six months
to do a sandbox update right that's the
key that's the key because at the end of
the day if when you have lack of
frequency right you're not in the sense
of engagement is not there it's almost
like well they don't care about this
game they're gonna take so long whatever
whatever then people just move on you
know but if you keep showing even if
it's small things like don't we've
talked about this ad nauseam before I'm
past flashpoints it even if you make
these small changes people like oh okay
they touch impulses this week gotta see
you know you jump in I remember d1 like
again not saying that they were frequent
but I remember when it was update it was
an excitement there's like okay see what
the meta is now let's go dust off some
of those old you know slow firing pulses
those gotta buff this week let me get my
spare change 25 out you know it's just
one of those things we're just like that
kind of tuning create breeds engagement
and that's what this game doesn't have
right or doesn't have engagement people
and that was the other thing Paul TAS
you mentioned I'm AI hope I'm not
duplicating myself here but he said the
fixed role issue was another thing they
tried to fix about but industy one they
said you know there's too many random
roles so it's really hard to bail
and if you have you know a gun with like
30 different roles certain perks when
they make it Opie and you know that may
happen so they're trying to make fixed
roles also they could change things more
frequently that hasn't hasn't gone into
a path though if that doesn't work I
mean and you're still gonna do these
really slow updates you know give it six
months for us together
gather all the random roles and then
finally do a patch but at least it gives
us something to get I agree man
absolutely absolutely so that one just I
don't know it's just so slow so no I
mean for me a sense of urgency I mean
you're looking at Iron Man or 66
crucible quitter penalties exotic
repetition reduction isn't even a
complete fix yeah I mean companion
interviewing I guess that team needs
something to do but shots no I mean the
guys who do the companion they're
literally they're a mobile development
team that's exactly what they do I mean
that's they're working on trying to make
things fine I'm not doing shots against
them but those things it's like that's
one of those pieces you probably put on
the patch notes and you definitely take
care of the team because people still
use the app but you don't there's a
highlight for your one point one feeling
that it's a bullet point the bullet
point because I use destiny I had a
manager anyway I haven't used the
commander thing in forever yeah Chronos
in chat basically saying it's like it's
like they just expected people to take
it is year one for year two and then as
a game rather than year four for destiny
for the ten-year franchise and it's like
they started it over and that's why so
many issues were like how do you how do
you start it all over you took 30 years
and you threw it off the table and you
went from scratch you went to four
before you took out random roles you
took out in there's so little in this
and I sit there and I'm doing the
nightfall solo and I'm sitting there
even bashing my head against it because
like no matter even though I'm gonna
finish the thing but even when I do why
why like I do it for the challenge
but again is there is no point in me
finishing that because it doesn't give
me anything new now there's gonna be
some unique rewards next week but I
swear if it's a reskin on a gun the odd
way I better not see that I better not
see no no no no faction
well you know Vanguard's now looking
weapons no no no faction no I was
looking at the fact the facts should
Armour and it's likely Titan shoulders
is literally the exact same thing as
this sounds like very lazy wiscons
very I mean I gotta call it what it is
and yeah it's rare for me to do that
because that's to me the strengths of
Bungie and strengths of Destiny to me is
the artists beautiful small they are
fantastic their art team Charlton and
like in in just like deep in the
marketing I always felt those are the
two things okay I'm making a hyper game
it can hyper game you know I mean and
they can show off some cool designs and
I feeling d2 we've regressed you know
we've had some cool - that they haven't
been any but but when it came to like
you said things like faction ornaments
and you know these type of armors and
stuff like that when you look at him
like damn these these are really nice
cans and then even with the guns the gun
variety you know there's a ton of reskin
you know in terms of archetype new stuff
so again something that has to be
addressed a man has to be and that's
this is kind of where is like and we can
probably keep going for a while and
stuff it's like it's painful to a point
we've got one point two coming we know
may is gonna be content but for all the
things we talk about be at random roles
be it a fourth weapon slot we wish it
was there for special weapons actually
work in that department right you know a
reason to have like an in-game level of
content I mean they just released free
DLC you want to make people happy
for destiny to Alex just about to say I
was like you give away this 1.2 for free
or if you already own the season pass
give me like I don't know 2020 20 like a
chunk of silver like new 8th do a nod to
the community to say hey if you haven't
got this one come back check it out it's
free fresh you ever bought the game yes
because most people have already got the
season pass then you're just gonna give
away digital like then just give away
silver or give away bright dust or both
and give us a bunch of engrams to say
hey we understand we want you guys to
come back have some fun with this stuff
it's like here's a token of appreciation
at least do something and that's the
thing they I don't think those are
opportunities I've heard other people
say that they've missed yes so when
they're certain there are certain times
when things aren't working you do
something in the game like hey in my
postmaster disappears right because when
people were all pissed at ever burst and
they never said hey here's like 5,000
bright note so you can buy a ghost in
the shader that are exotic and that's
their good point yeah I think that's
exactly what was going on I mean they
it's almost like that they need to
replicate the problem they need to
replicate a Rainbow six siege moment the
problem is I just don't see it possible
based on the financial infrastructure of
Activision I'm gonna be completely
honest I can't see them foregoing even
though that would be the ultimate
goodwill right look we botched but you
come out with a miracle but we botched
we heard your feedback and this is what
we're doing come a better uh you know
Anna Bray in the wall mine DLC you know
free for those or whatever whatever and
you get engagement because that's what
you need right now you know having a
little free weekend here and there ain't
gonna do it you know it need to do
something drastic and I that's where it
is right now we're at drastic measures
like patient like that the heart rates
not there right there it's like you
about flatlined at this point fax so we
look at 1.2 we've got a prestige mode
and you're like how does the prestige
mode take that long prestige mode for
eater of worlds from December comes in
May five months later seasonable
seasonal crucible or in Kings okay
that's a baby step yeah private matches
which should read custom games if
private matches are still just a way for
me and you to play against each other by
choosing to and that's it that's no
giant waste of me all
holy crap if it actually happens we'll
see it's just the fifty for this one and
then whatever the next big thing is
gonna fix fault if it's just fifty I
think that's the blue Gary is just gonna
walk out a fire - yeah that's it I'm
gonna throw my favors in there I'm out
you guys win vault space is fixed you
guys can run it it's like Fran Shawn
CJ you guys can just take it over I'll
come back when the vault space is fixed
I cannot do this like I wouldn't just
fall out of my chair also know one thing
emote will I'm like really like how is
that how how is that spores I gotta jump
in on that one that that's bull not
embarrassing let's just call it what it
is because you know why it's
embarrassing it's actually embarrassing
for two reasons one because it's been
clamour from d1 yeah it was like I mean
every verse was all about the emotes we
go to is his thing it to me they did
kicking it kicking their own self
because it's like your whole spiel is
ever verse right microtransactions
emotes all the microtransactions that
you can get away with let's be honest
like when you see something really cool
a long man yeah literally has taken the
Michael Jackson so much money and I will
not be ashamed to say that is one thing
invest in the Iowa Michael when I see a
dance of some pop culture reference you
know I remember when the young d1 they
had there was it they had the Drake the
hotline bling hmm dance they I mean they
had a lot of pop culture stuff and you
put those things out frequent people are
going about it now could you imagine
being able to switch between all these
different cool emotes that destiny has
doesn't it largely has domestic modes so
it's just like missed opportunity and
that's that's financial opportunity
missed I don't see how to watch that one
no I was like it's coming to one point
to it's like somehow I worry that that's
getting your person you're like okay
you've got exact mass to work so I'm
like they should just be on there now
cuz nobody uses exotics like if you're
gonna I mean you can rework the master
work situation maybe do your exotic
tuning but if you want us to use a
master work or an exotic like even if it
was mid a multi-tool I might use that as
my Scout instead right and still get
orbs from it that shouldn't be like a
crazy factor of like okay can make orbs
like why is that breaking everything I
don't know seasonal vendor progression
I'm kinda out may unless the vendors
actually have something worthwhile
exactly or something or something to
grind for yeah faction rally
improvements desperately needed and they
said they I mean they they know what
they want to do how they're gonna do it
I don't know
and then exotic exotic weapon in sandbox
changes and this was another thing where
I go back to where I feel like the whole
game was rushed right they execs feel
weak yes so many of them do yes I mean
they don't feel and they said hey we
want to make exotics exotics and that
goes back to my line of like no kidding
but I'm usually much more crude terms
[Laughter]
you want exotics for one you throw them
at us and then they don't even matter
yeah so if you throw him at us and I was
grinding for stuff and I was like hey I
got those I own safe clubs again I'm
like you know what I got a couple of but
I'm worried he wearing them cuz they're
really cool so cool like that I mean if
it was something I was wearing but I
don't even care if I get them three
times four times ten times like who
gives a damn
and then finally heroic strike modifiers
why is this not you have a whole
playlist of heroic strikes sorry if I
got loud there guys you know like you
have heroic strikes there lit no you
just literally play random strikes for a
milestone but milestones don't matter so
unless you just need some gear that was
the whole point they were fun like the
daily the daily cruise the daily
crucible the daily story the weekly
story the heroic strikes with modifiers
like that was a reason to go just
absolutely that was part of our daily
routine that was those are our rituals
didn't get to daily done you get to you
nightfall you
crucible you know I mean you see what
you see what the burns are you don't
mean like that was it's a big deal
there's those are big data as part of
that culture and that that's nothing
that's missing there's no reason to log
in you know every day because of the
lack of Chase and the lack of things to
do mm-hmm and I think that rounds it up
and then that's where we're at is like
all of this can come out we'll have
unless they drop like a taking King full
overhaul with quest and I don't think
they can do that in May where I great on
its content it's gonna be whatever the
final raid lair is it's gonna be the
expansion it's gonna be whatever story
missions they are if they take a little
longer hopefully it's more than a few
story missions and I said if you add
strikes in there that are copies of the
story missions I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot
shoot and I'm gonna shoot lots of things
but I'm gonna be a little ticked off
because that was that was lazy yes
those two strikes on mercury are some of
the laziest content I've seen from desti
and I know that's harsh for me to say
but that's literally just saying here's
a mission cut off the end here it's a
strike like if it I would rather have
one new strike and then maybe have one
that was like that but if you don't have
one new strike it was literally five
missions hmm yeah you're right you go
play that you can play the missions
again but you can do him the strikes but
like that there was nothing there was a
very minimal added to the game you had
the mercury circle and you had the
infinite forests which they have
completely not utilized yeah
locked off yeah so I mean I don't know
what they're gonna do for what Phobos or
whatever snowy planet we will keep
seeing in all the pictures but whatever
it is man it needs to be so yeah we'll
see on next week it's a big one Tuesday
Tuesday's babe I want to see how to
handle it how the game feels it feels
hot please we're really feeling fast I
want to see the mirror I want to I'm
gonna bus out I'm dusting off a lot of
guns I want to see what's actually
effective I'm actually gonna go with
like the release you know I'm probably
gonna jump on the pulses just to give
them a shot I know what I'm not touching
is them grenade launches someone else
can test that blast radius and I was
sitting there I was even looking at the
new monarchy thing and I'm like unless
they take the blast radius from where
on the bar which probably was like 40 45
percent 200% and then you take that
number multiply it by like 20 like it
needs to be stupidly good otherwise
grenade launcher it's a hard thing to
hit with in the first place or make it
to where the certain ones that explained
eed to be so much better you have Cronus
he was like the modifiers when we were
talking about those for heroic strikes
and it was like he said so much fun arc
burned with fourth horseman and I was
like and then throw specialist on there
you would melt some faces if you had
four horses arteburn and specialist oh
man you'd be like all this elite just
came out alright this elite just died
okay it was that fast like never feel
that powerful don't feel that way and
and again this is why one point one
point four is important because it's
it's the crucible side we got the go
fast stuff we got the matter stuff and
then we also we underrating the PvE side
they are making some adjustments as far
as making things more awful let's see
how that stuff plays and again the
building blocks baby steps you know
obviously we're you know we want this
thing to try to try to come back the
game has to play well first once the
gameplay went well then you get the
systems and then from there you can
start talking about DLC because at the
end of the day it's a tough sell to ask
someone to Punk out cash when you know
said I will assume that most people who
bought destiny right now bought locked
in with expansions one and two on their
meal so I think they're okay on that end
but coming you know the taken Queen so
to speak mmm they've got a tough sell
because if it still hasn't been you know
in a serviceable state and people are
still complaining and it's still where
it's at that's tough to ask someone to
pay cuz you know they're gonna charge
thirty forty dollars you know how they
do know that's gonna be thirty four
because what was taken King was forty I
believe was forty before they gonna say
full expansion yadda yadda yadda and
people gonna be like hey fool me once
you know so they've got
to get goodwill back this is the
goodwill tour 2018 they've got to get it
back these are the steps so it starts
here this is the roadmap community feels
it too so I was like you've got content
creators that are you know having to
play other things because the traffic's
not there because people don't look as
much like you'll have I mean Paul Tassie
writes the one article but again there's
there's not even that much to write
about so hopefully next so we could give
it a little bit you know it'll be like a
tiny little shot in the leg just to be
like hey it's still we're trying but I
think in the end it's still gonna take
yeah I still I I was talking last night
with my chat and I was kind of getting
down the road of there's so many things
and such a little time I know it's March
and I know we're looking at September
but I mean you're only talking about six
months for them to basically almost need
to rebuild they almost need to rebuild
the whole thing and I I mean they it's
to that level though when you look at
the things that don't I mean you're
doing a sandbox fix but you've got the
way stories are built you've got I Cora
doing her story thing put those back on
the map you've got just the random roll
so you pretty much need to rebuild your
whole weapon system you've got maybe
needing and needing another slot you
need armor to be completely different so
the stats actually matter that's still
one of the things that bugs me I mean
it's like so many of your main base
systems besides the framework of how a
gun fires acts look of the world like
the artistry and like the feel you you
have like a foundation for a house you
maybe have some boards up for a frame
but there's so much in the middle that's
missing you basically got to gut the
house and you almost got to do it again
and that's that's kind of what I feel it
almost needs and I don't know how they
do that I don't know how they justify it
with Activision I don't know how they
win the trust back but it's gonna take
something major as you said it takes
something extreme whether it's you know
making taking king 2.0 or taking Queen
whatever maybe they make that thing what
if they do it what if they did it for
$10 or even 20
it to be the we're in that kind of
territory you know the problem is big
old Activision's on track I just don't
see it man like the only people like I
said we they had a good shot I mean they
they just went um first for siege they
just did like a a big weekend like I did
they did like a free weekend before
their major DLC content drop and so they
had people playing for a whole weekend
you know getting used to the new changes
the new meta so to speak on siege for
people that went and dropped again
because C's was not people forget siege
was not well-received it was not you
know it was it listen I love the game
but it had its issues and a lot of
people are like nope not this is not for
me and it it slowly built yourself back
up
you know continually patching quicker
patching quicker response times and
things of that nature speed agency
knowing your game is you know on the way
out and listening to player feedback
constantly and then slowly but surely
they got themselves where the game
actually played good they fix a lot of
the issues and complain about and then
he made it free for a weekend and then
boom right before they little may DLC in
their side it came out right then so now
you it played good you felt good and now
you're like okay I can plunk down that
little cash for a DLC I like what they
did you know then you justify it and and
like you said that the fear is is it
enough time you know is six-month legit
there's so many fundamental things that
people are upset with are the wrong with
destiny to is it legitimately enough
time and that that's the big question
that's the question and that's why I
think follows not on this map because I
don't know if they know what they can
commit to what they're looking at or if
any dates might change like it's like if
it takes a little longer but it was
better and that's the boat I'm on at
this point I want to enjoy destiny to so
many of us do and if it takes longer for
it to get there I know you so it's like
you and Doc are like hey you're gonna
lose the player base but link take
something take some of the major games
like
if they just took Nissa t2 they know
it's a wash they've got to rebuild it
back but they do a destiny three but
maybe it comes sooner than expected
as opposed to a three-year cycle or
something and they rework the whole
thing they bring it back like then you'd
be have a decent shot like take your
time to rebuild those things don't throw
everything away this time right and
that's going in progress but then like
just do patches maybe I don't know it's
I can't decide I know actually it's
tough like it's tough because it's to
school Authority gyms it's like there's
nothing there's no wrong answer it's
just how are you received by your
community if you go take that time and
you get it right then it's about okay
when do you get it right when do you
drop it we already talked last flash
point about you know content release
schedules Red Dead Redemption Call of
Duty you don't say like when when is
right then you know the elephants in the
room anthem some struggles right now but
that's a whole different matter entirely
it's out there
yeah it's competition in your space mr.
destiny it's a competition so at the end
of the day it's like it's so key to when
these things happen so part of me is
like that that's where I leaned toward
the other way was like what maybe they
gotta just they gotta really push this
man they really gotta get this thing
going now keep it in the mind [ __ ] cuz
people don't care anymore
stuff it off man Janet's a fool killer
in my chat he was like so what you're
saying is Bungie itself needs a go-fast
update they need to go fast
I mean if certain things take time just
start tweaking with stuff being like hey
this triquet have your artists you know
you've got six week okay this is our
nightfall schedule we're gonna loose you
guys focus on this one so we can drop it
now so you could have dropped it like
they want time for the artists to do it
right well you have six weeks until
things drop you're not gonna drop them
all at the same time absolutely won't
give them away do one week at a time
like find your way to you have a weekly
game cycle right that's your advantage
on some points and you know I might put
you know my fear is again not to make
this all on one that it's just that my
fear is if you notice a boy mark
Noseworthy and Luke Smith they're not
involved anymore right this is how
damaged cars mole even deej is kind of
in the lurch right he's not really in
the mix anymore everything's been thrown
on you know damaged right now
Christopher bare you know but it's like
to me you can't even be thinking about
destiny 3 right now people are gonna say
no way you've got you you've got to have
all resources on deck
yeah for two you have to save two from
the doldrums right it's so I know that
future planning says you know you work
on the next game and I know that's how
the business works I get it
this is a game no one's coming back so I
don't know that's just me no it's like
and yeah there's so much up in the air
so it's like are they working on taking
King to or taking Queen whatever we call
it are they already kind of dabbling
with destiny 3 we don't know what
they're doing it's a huge studio and
there's multiple teams there's multiple
Studios working on this house yeah bro
this is Bungie it's their DNA that's
what they do they don't you tell it it
it feels like this team's not talking to
that team and you know you can't do that
anymore they disconnect God to stop it
that was why I was like you're the live
team work on this it's like you guys
were so he saw the live team things kept
getting better strikes were good content
even in a social space with like a
findable ghost in there and none of
that's in destiny - what would you guys
just like leave them in the other side
of the you guys have two buildings and
they just go separately
we don't look at that we don't maybe one
we're gonna do no we don't talk to you
like I don't know man
I don't know how somebody disconnects
happen and I think like the world knows
it
so I mean you take a halo one to a halo
to you didn't throw everything else you
added to it
facts facts make maze gonna be telling
my Lancer if we can keep doing this
little chat that we do it's like we love
it but yeah it's like if me if May is a
bomb drop and they early fail on that
one man that's gonna be the world of the
landscape of destiny to is gonna look
like the landscape of a fallout game
there's not gonna be a lot less exactly
perfect analogy perfect left they're
gonna be real balloons from scraps oh
all right guys I think we have rambled a
little bit here and covered stuff but
yeah the week is interesting but yeah
sites like planet destiny just like
shutting it down content creators moving
on we don't know what's coming things
like the patch like exotic repetition
Eve isn't even fixed for me that would
just hit me right mark because I've been
preaching and hoping for that one it's
just like no no dying over here Tuesday
all happen we'll do another one of these
probably next Friday and have some patch
notes to talk about and maybe the weekly
update is like hey the patches out here
look for April for the marketing
campaign to get going absolutely I'm
gonna I'm banking I'm gonna be in PAX
East and uh and then about two weeks so
I'm banking you know as far as the
actual marketing schedule that they
should really start pumping destiny to
DLC now like this is we should net you
know five weeks out mold where they
start promoting it so we'll see how they
handle and hopefully they have a
presence there and you get some inside
scoop for the flash yeah well we will
wrap this thing up for all you guys who
did follow and yeah thank you guys for
tuning in this morning yeah you want to
wrap it up
yeah man said 'lord Carlito here you
already know where the farming on
Twitter at Lord [ __ ] neato
and of course Church is Sunday the Iowa
Cass will be going down this Sunday at
1:00 p.m. Eastern on the inner circle
Network channel you know we've got a
guest cooking I was trying to finalize
it should be a just trying to make sure
he's locked in there should be a fun
time at the roundtable talking
everything in gaming you know we got
some cool tap is going on we got some
CDs to talk about it's gonna be a fun
it's like and there's just more coming
to steal like see a thieves there's
another one you know regardless of how
people feel you know these are these
again here's a question what's out deep
do you think that game is not that well
played on the but it's but again it's
still a different experience for some
people and some people make their own
little worlds out of it so so one more
thing in the world of competition yeah
yep for me as well you guys know where
to find me twitch.tv slash Montes time
you guys are watching me right here
twitter.com amount us as well
but shout out to uh Lord Cognito iron
Lords podcast those guys are always have
a nice entertaining chat fun passionate
group over there they definitely get too
worked up at times it's fun to watch it
go down yeah I got my nightfall solo
posted up last night so yeah so proud of
you oh man that was a rough one last
week just trying and still not finishing
I got to the boss like 10 times probably
I can get the last bar of the boss and
then it's literally the point where he
basically continually rotates
continually spawns ads if you aren't in
the right spot at the right time you
start the whole fight over and I'm gonna
watch that Soteria queued like get on
the platform and just kind of pump out
rockets real quick and throw and I was
literally debating it was like okay so
do and this is why I'm wondering is like
okay do I switch supers wait like six
minutes for it to charge up which will
be nice next week when I don't have to
wait that long wait for it to charge up
and then just throw a rock it's hammers
and everything to destroy melt him and
it's like I just didn't switch and I
kept dying so I was like screw it I took
my time I got this one done but yeah
check me out on youtube as well guys it
savant is everywhere if you look me up
that's pretty much where you'll find me
on Xbox Playstation easy way it's a
weird name but it's definitely unique so
it's what I've got everywhere so to all
you guys checking us out as always thank
you for tuning in thank you for the
support and for wherever you guys are at
around the world good afternoon good
morning or good evening have a good one
- man one point one point fool if they
save you